the award for the best actress of 1950  will be presented by the winner of last  year's Best Actor Award mr. Broadrick  properly remembering my feeling at this  time last year I'll get on with it the  nominations for the Best Actress are  Miss Anne Baxter and All About Eve 20th  Century Fox Miss Betty Davis All About  Eve 20th Century Fox Miss Judy Holliday  born yesterday Columbia Eleanor Parker  encaged Warner Brothers and Miss Gloria  Swanson and Sunset Boulevard paramount  the winner is Judy Holliday  ladies and gentlemen ladies and  gentlemen miss Holliday is not here miss  Belle or would accept the award for  I'm very honored to be asked to accept  this award for Julie Holliday for her  radiant performance in born yesterday I  don't know exactly what she wants me to  say daddy be safe to say that she's very  happy and very grateful  you